I'm in a room full of geniuses right now
you guys are telling me that you these
are the only artistic people you know
I'm listening to people you know who
still live at their mother's house and
still trying to figure it out I'm just
trying to spread that peace and love
when I was poor man and it's about these
cool Vibes it's about this inspiration
he's an American rapper record producer
director actor and model he's a member
of the hip-hop group ASAP Mob In 2011 he
released his debut mixtape and signed a
two-year three million dollar record
deal with RCA he's ASAP Rocky and here's
my take on his top 10 rules for Success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well also as
you are writing something down it's much
more likely to stick in your head too
enjoy
thank you
and you know not just getting to my
hip-hop form but that's just what it is
okay and I'm just trying to set the bar
that you can do you want to do because
the world is yours
disregard the ladies walking past just
for you ladies
you can do whatever you want the world
is yours
and I'm telling the young cash Our
Generation don't discriminate against
anybody because we're all one generation
and that's something important you know
I mean who would have thought a ghetto
kid with gold teeth and french braids
from the hood will be in Vogue in GQ on
the same month in the same month at the
same time about the same [__] who would
have a thought interview magazine would
have did an eight page spread who would
have ever thought Complex magazine to
cover with a gay designer Jeremy Scott
which was an idol of mine because I
admired his passion and I admired his
art since the late team who would have
thought I would have did that you know
why because I didn't let the negativity
hold me back and that's what's holding
out back negativity man straight up
that's real don't give a [__] with
nobody say do what feels right to you
you know who you are do you know who you
are and be you and I'm me I'm happy
being me feel good to be me right now
man straight up the question was when
you started first knew that you had that
moment that that confidence when you
felt it when I was poor man you know
it's just like I don't think confidence
is something that you could buy it's
something that's embedded in you you
know and some people gain it with
success that's just like the icing on
the cake but your poor man with
confidence is Unstoppable almost
invincible
laughs
it made me look at you like uh what do
you mean and it's just like you know
well I look at it like you should let
the people choose it's a day and age
where everything is optional you know
anything you need is that the is that
our fingertips the click of a button
yeah man get what I'm saying so you
should let the fans pick what they want
as a single you know why should we why
should we drive like songs and program
them into radio just to drive it into
their heads I mean I think you should
pick what people like right and give it
to them by giving the album and I got a
single he got a single he got a single
crazy because that's what this is I
think each song I mean as a whole it
makes sense they compliment each other
it's like for me I wanted to try to
create a masterpiece just as much as
possible the way I knew but I feel like
each of them like singly individually
they they stand on their own legs and I
I think that a lot of individual people
are gonna be like well you know this one
really spoke to me but this one is cool
you know I didn't really get that that's
what I wanted I didn't expect I didn't
want to make everyone try to like
everything it's just I wanted to make
art and hope everyone would like
everything it's all about inspiration
right now people neglect that so much
man I think nowadays I mean it's the
obvious it's all about making them [__]
and we all want to make money I want to
make money not gonna lie but I would
prefer to do it the right way by making
and producing art that I feel
is my the best I could do anybody could
sell a record today make a song about 10
minutes more stuff all jokes aside you
know you just gotta be catchy and you
know get some bomb posts and you can do
it and that's not I'm not knocking
anybody for what they do I'm just saying
what I want to prefer but I prefer to do
what I want to do with my art and how I
want it viewed and you know perceived I
want people to know that I put my
everything into my art you know even I
put it before myself not being seen in
two years creating you know not putting
up you know any projects like this is
just me creating and you know trying to
involve myself maybe you could talk
about your like uh your name why you
stylized it like that
um especially on the pretty Flocka and
who that's in on March too I felt like
with the name Rock Kim it's like being
named after like Tupac Shakur or Michael
Jordan you know it was I mean those
shoes are too big to try to fulfill and
I wanted to kind of pioneer my own
legacy you know I wanted to leave back
my own path I didn't want to be like oh
well yeah everybody knew about him
because he came out and he had that
famous rapper's name and nah man I
wanted to start respectfully I wanted to
earn my name and that was the whole
point of this last album at long last
ASAP because it's basically I the in the
abbreviations is a lot a-l-l-a
and it's like the return of the goddamn
seat Rakim was the god EMC and I'm
finally accepting that my name is Rock
Kim and I'm taking ownership of it and I
just want to make rock Kim my mother my
father people Slick Rick Big Daddy Kane
those kind of people I want to make them
proud at a time when New York hip-hop
was like not even being respected yeah
how did you and your boys put this whole
thing together man you as a leader of a
movement like you know how you put
yourself on you put a whole movement
together it's because like you know I
had a support system it wasn't just like
you know I the whole mob was with this
and not only that man like uh yams man
you know anything I ever wanted to do he
was he was supportive you know he got it
he got my vision I think we was just a
bunch of young Visionaries that happened
to get together and that only happens
every once in a few that doesn't always
happen often when everybody has an
Eclectic Vision an individual vision of
their own you know all together with
collection everybody knew each other's
strengths and exactly and weaknesses and
stuff so it really helped and I feel
like when we came in I was our concerned
wasn't being the dopest [__] out of
New York or being the most successful
lot of that we just was on just doing
our own thing and I think that's what
helped because we wasn't trying to do
what everybody else was doing and now
that we're still doing our own thing
we're going to give people a new
lifestyle to adapt to you get what I'm
saying because time change I gave him a
style four years ago here we are again
at long last you know and I know like
2014 like you you've been on the record
as saying well you haven't seen the
interview with double XL was saying how
you know 2014 was a rough year in
culture and you guys weren't really that
inspired and then you actually had
tweeted out that you thought it was a
terrible year in music culture and unity
and that 2015 is The Rebirth of it all
in the year of The Underdogs mark my
words do y'all agree with me on that
this year alone what we this is the
fourth month right we already have
releases from some of the greatest
artists in hip-hop alone like I'm on the
internet and I'm hearing these little
kids that's coming out and these [__]
is fresh like they way better than all
these old [__] that's in the game like
I'm telling you man it's all about the
youth it's all about tomorrow and I
don't think just because a person has a
million dollars in a bank account that
that makes some incredible artists and
not you know I'm listening to people you
know who still live at their mother's
house and still trying to figure it out
as long as you got some Jiggy to say
imma listen and if you got a dope visual
to go with it I'm bored well I'm a kid
too myself so part of my language but
you know real life stuff with you guys
you know and uh I hope that you can
respect that and I hope you can feel
that you know because we're all real
people at the end of the day you know
when all the lights are off we're all
real people you got to be who you are
you know and uh I'm quite sure you guys
know this already right your Geniuses
right yeah
but let me get back to the topic at hand
I'm going all over the place did I say I
was happy to be here
I feel like we had to we're at a day and
age where well I know we had a day and
age where these companies the radio the
media these markets man it's it's
getting really
it's getting scary for them because a
lot of independent independent companies
or just personalities are coming
and doing it the right way like people
like Spotify you know coming and taking
some like streaming if YouTube and and
Vimeo were places that you would go to
go see videos all day you didn't think
nothing of it they found out how to
monetize at the streaming service and
now that's they're bigger than the
labels
so we're looking at iTunes and Spotify
and all these other guys those are going
to be the biggest record labels within
the next two years you know and people
are not they're not seeing what what I
noticed is
as a rapper or as an artist with the
internet I can make my own label you can
you can do it yourself I mean obviously
you know you can't you might not have
the money that those companies have but
trust me there's a way and
I think
I think it's obvious to them I think
it's obvious to the world that stuff
like radio stuff like you know the old
marketing formulas they don't apply to
my generation and our attention span
these kids nowadays man you gotta
entertain them really quick or they
gonna click to something else man you
know I mean I can admit it I'll get
online and I start you know looking at
ads and whatever and I'm just closing
out things out I really if it doesn't
spark my interest if it's not funny if
it's not ignorant half the time I won't
watch it you know and that's just me if
it's not something that's entertaining
and uh
you know dealing with uh
a record label and being an artist at
this day and age and is in doing things
from an independent standpoint I get to
see both sides of the grass and you know
I get to see the politics within it and
and the flaws
you know and uh I think
as far as people like you guys Geniuses
and and my generation to come I'm more
scared of you guys because you guys are
way more advanced you know and the kids
after you gonna be twice as advanced as
you guys are man you know how like they
always used to say like respect your
elders man it's like the other way
around now man like the tables have
turned man these kids are geniuses man
and you know that's really you know
that's what I'm basically up here trying
to articulate you know without feeling
like I'm talking to myself but yeah when
I started ASAP part of me I didn't start
ASAP I joined in 2007 it was a crew from
Harlem if you guys don't know about it
that's my crew and uh
it was a bunch of just teenage kids that
just wanted to do teenage things you
know I don't think I have to specify at
this point right and uh
basically you know that leads to nothing
because you just you know wake up and
before you know you just spent all
summer having fun you don't have
anything accomplished you don't have any
money you don't have a job nothing right
I looked around and I just said man we
got to do something about this we need
to utilize each other because together
we're all a collective and that was the
obvious I think the main part
in our day and age is just identifying
any stating the lobbyists like Common
Sense you'd be surprised how many people
lack it you know and um
I use my common sense and uh
it led to me trying to
use the internet as an outlet
to Market myself to get my brand out
there because nowadays if if I'm about
show hands how many people are aspiring
artists out there rather be music you
know painting or no really thank you we
got one artist I know it's more than
that music dance theater cinematography
is Art you know the Arts that's it
so I'm in a room full of geniuses right
now you guys are telling me that you
these are the only artistic people yeah
don't be shy I came to talk to y'all
today what's up how many people watch
your hands have a passion for art don't
be ashamed it doesn't mean you're a
loser you're gonna be like Basquiat and
do heroin it's okay all right cool
I think we're finally getting to know
one another today you know
uh
what I will say is I'm quite sure
everything that I'm saying you guys are
so Advanced you know already and uh it
is I'm just thinking obvious it's common
sense and um
for those of you who are trying to be
artists or who have it in them
there's just so many different the ways
that you would
Market a brand as far as a company
an incorporation is the same way you
have to Market yourself these days
because a brand is no longer like just a
company it could be an individual
for instance if ASAP Rocky goes out and
you know which this would never happen
but shoots a hundred people it would
mess up my brand
I did it as one person no but I mean
it's common sense right I'm just
breaking it down to the basics for y'all
right now you know but it's it's the
truth it will mess up my brand as a
person what about my friends who had
nothing to do with it what about my you
know that's that's just that's that's
what I mean by that when I tell you guys
that we're all a brand and um
I came here to do fashion just like in
hip-hop who can't only set the bar you
also have to raise it here's a look at
some fashion do's and don'ts
do be unique and independent with your
style and choices don't wear NFL jersey
with your name in the back of it unless
you're willing to take a hit for that
team
foreign
do when it comes to Fashion break out
the box take a risk don't literally wear
a box
dude I have a hairstyle that complements
your overall Style
don't
don't shave your side burnings above
your ears you look like a damn narc or
something dude dress casually when a
situation calls for it don't dress like
you're golfing even when you're golfing
don't push me Bob now is not the time I
swear to God I hate the way golf is
dressed do just like writing lyrics
sometimes just keep it simple don't over
accessorize as people are going to end
up pity in the food
[Music]
where the Canadian tuxedo no don't wear
the Canadian tuxedo ever
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Chad Britton
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did ASAP Rocky say that had
the biggest impact on you what are you
going to take from his message and
immediately apply to your life for
business somehow leave it down in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Tina Chang Tina thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and making that fun
YouTube video around it as well I really
really really appreciate the support
this is my
attack so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
based on a movement that you guys start
after games pass called tweet again
tweet like games and basically it's
taken his funniest quotes and just you
know uh showcasing them I think uh
I think his his state of mind is just
his personality it was never broadcasted
or just people didn't you would have to
be a a true cult follower to really
while he was alive to understand you
know yams you know little Newport but I
think that it I think now that he's gone
it's like one of those things it's like
awareness and it's just spreading and
his importance in hip-hop and how he his
contribution to hip-hop people was
starting to see his influence and it's
not just ASAP Rocky like it's not just
me influencing people and setting Trends
it's like my cruise type but most of all
like my best friend man he had an L
vision and I think you know a lot of
people miss and love them for that
because you know not only not only just
music and stuff people he was a personal
guy with a lot of people I didn't even
know you know what I'm saying like he
had personal relationship so I think
that's kind of tight it's important and
I'm just trying to spread that peace and
love amongst hip-hop and amongst the
brothers and sisters man you know what
I'm saying